The answer here is just income level. Gender would not
be considered an ordered factor, since it doesn't make sense
to rank male and female groups. The military service and
children variables are binary variables with yes or no values, so
these really wouldn't make sense to order either. Using the
same thinking, it doesn't really make sense to order the levels
of country and state variables, since we wouldn't rank those
either. We wouldn't really say one location is better than another.
And finally, cheese falls into the same bucket as military service and children,
because it's binary, so this one's out too. The income levels actually have
a natural order to them where we can group the buckets from lowest
to highest, or from highest to lowest. That's what make it an ordered factor.